karine cloutier crise gatti sont en
couple depuis quatre ans mais depuis le
début de la pandémie
ils sont séparés contre leur grille à
cause de la fermeture de la frontière
canado américaine
ils se parlent plusieurs fois par jour
via vidéoconférence
mais depuis le mois de mars 400
kilomètres les séparent c'est
ratissaient les motive mais surtout
parce qu'on a peur des dames on n'y
croit pas les époux et les conjoints de
fait sont autorisés à traverser la
frontière depuis un mois mais karine
cloutier crise gatti ne sont pas mariés
ils n'habitent pas ensemble elle
pourrait rentrer aux états unis par
avion mais elle veut rester proche de sa
mère âgée dont elle s'occupe
et à quatre heures de route le on
aimerait juste pouvoir se voir avec des
consignes de manière un peu plus fluide
mais que ça soit reconnue aussi parce
que là pour l'instant on a l'impression
que notre relation à vos vieilles
racines
camille lafleur rousseau vit la même
situation
son conjoint est à brooklyn le fait de
pas savoir c'est combien de temps est-ce
qu'on va être séparé cinq mois six mois
sept mois un nom c'est surtout ceux qui
crient de l'anxiété je dirais elle fait
partie d'un groupe facebook qui compte
des dizaines de témoignages comme le
sien et joueurs audois qui ont droit de
traverser la frontière
eux ils y ont droit de passer avant que
les membres de nos familles aient le
droit de passer plus de 4300 personnes
ont signé cette pétition sur le site de
la chambre des communes
ils demandent au gouvernement
d'assouplir les règles pour les couples
qui ne sont pas mariés ou conjoints de
fait pas impossible dit cet expert met
pas simple non plus si vous n'êtes pas
l'un ou l'autre
comment va prouver ça est ce qu'une
preuve d'engagement est ce que des
photos de fiançailles est ce qu une
lettre commune de famille bref on
commence à tomber dans quelque chose qui
est un petit peu moins simple qu'un
certificat de mariage mais c'est
possible
l'aller et le retour un certificat de
mariage c'est ce qu'espère matt s'en va
chercher en islande
elle et son conjoint devait se marier
cet été au québec
les plans ont changé l'islande me permet
d'y aller le canada ne me permets peut
donc la seule solution qui me restent
ils me rendre là-bas pour les mariés
puis on va enfin avoir une vie semi
normal s'il ya pas de deuxième vague on
espère qu'on est peu mais si on est le
non moins embêtant sans le ministre de
la sécurité publique berlin n'était pas
disponible pour une entrevue son bureau
dit que toute décision est prise pour
assurer la sécurité des canadiens
ici elle car on radio canada montréal